Did you know you can actually get kicked out
of Nook's Cranny? Yeah, me neither until a few
days ago but today I'm gonna show you ten animal
crossing new horizons secrets and tips you need to
know and we're starting right now people of the
internet retro raconteur here and welcome back
to another animal crossing new horizons video
the game has been out for several months now
and I'm still discovering new things now some of
these items I'm about to share with you are just
funny bizarre and a little strange but others
will actually help you in your daily Island
routine so let's get right into it number one you
can get kicked out of nooks cranny I wasn't just
joking in the beginning if you've ever gone into
nook's cranny before they closed at 10:00 p.m.
you already know you'll be free to browse and
buy items until you're finished you know common
courtesy they'll promptly lock the door behind
you but hey at least you get your shopping done
but have you ever seen what happens if you walk
in the moment just before it hits 10:00 p.m. okay
still don't believe me here see for yourself
if you walk in right as it switches over to
10:00 they'll kick you out let's see if we get
kicked out how to get kicked out of nooks cranny
as much as we look forward to seeing you here
again another time they're not putting up with
any dude you don't even have to push the button
you don't even have to push the button you know
how rare that is an animal crossing you have to
press the button to advance every single menu of
dialogue in the game as you can hear on screen
I open the door just before the clock started
chiming for 10 p.m. number 2 there's more
to sable than meets the eye when you first
unlock the able sisters shop you may be a bit
turned off by sable she's always focused on her
work and never gives you much attention but if
you're polite and keep talking to her each day
your persistence will pay off if you talk
to sable for 6 straight days you'll start
to consider you a friend and I don't want to
spoil it here but as you keep talking to sable
you'll actually learn she has quite a tragic
past once the two of you become friends you
can continue talking to her each day for free
Furniture patterns you'll be able to use these
patterns on certain furniture items by going to
the customize menu from any DIY workbench note
that note all furniture items support the custom
patterns but for the ones that do you'll look for
the pattern option in your menu from there you'll
see the complete list of patterns you've received
from sable number three some items have special
properties just when you think you've figured
out how items behave in the game you'll learn
something new usually these are little things
such as the t-rex fossil reacting when you press
a next to it or the fact that some bugs and fish
have different enclosures or no enclosure
at all in the case of the snapping turtle
the large fountain item you can craft in the game
also reacts every hour with a higher stream of
water for me personally its little details like
this that give the game that extra bit of charm
and polish what special item properties have you
guys discovered so far I'd love to try them out
for myself so post a comment down below to let
me know number 4 you can fall in a hole okay
this one is a little strange I admit there are
actually two ways you can fall into a hole the
first way is if you attempt to pull vault over a
river and there's a hole waiting for you on the
other side the other is by use of an item known as
a pitfall seed there's a DIY recipe out there so
you can craft your own creative fans of the game
have even devised clever games around the use of
pitfall seeds just check out this clip from one of
my latest twitch streams yikes Oh number 5 turnip
prices follow a pattern so most of you probably
know by now that buying and selling turnips is
by far the fastest most efficient way to make
bells in new horizon your turnip prices will
actually follow one of four patterns each week
you'll be hoping for a small spike large spike or
fluctuating pattern the only one you really don't
want to see is the decreasing pattern what's even
better is there's an entire website dedicated
to helping you track your turnip prices from
week to week I made a whole separate video about
tracking your turnip prices so I'll include a link
in the top right corner and also down in the
description number 6 tracking museum donations
made easy donating to the museum and seeing
its steady transformation into the epicenter
of culture and knowledge on your island is quite
the rewarding endeavor at times though it's easy
to lose track of what fish sea creatures and bugs
you've donated never fear your critterpedia does
more than just show what you've caught so far if
you look for the little owl icon on each critter
you'll also know if the item has been donated
to the museum or not so this means any critters
without the owl icon have not yet been donated to
the museum this is especially helpful if you share
your island with family members or friends number
7 pressing down on the d-pad will quickly put away
your current tool I'm always honest with you guys
so I have to come clean here my 6 year old is the
one who discovered this seriously in our early
days playing the game he watched as I went into
pockets or item selection wheel each time I wanted
to put away my current tool he then proceeded to
share with me that all it takes is a simple press
of the down button on the d-pad to quickly stow
away your tool simple but the time you'll save
definitely adds up number eight the nook shopping
app on your nook phone this is one of those
I had no idea was in the game and I've been
playing for months by this point you've probably
gotten used to heading over to resident services
and accessing the kiosk each day to see what new
items are for sale but after you've purchased 100
total items from the kiosk you'll get to download
the app onto your phone which means nook shopping
anywhere anytime note that any items purchased
by redeeming nook miles do not count you'll
need to purchase them directly through the Nook
shopping menu at the kiosk you can also easily
keep track of how many items you purchase so
far just check your Nook miles challenge page
and look for the one called shop to it this will
show you exactly how many items you've purchased
so far you probably already know you're limited
to buying five items per day from the kiosk but
if you want to speed up the process of getting to
100 buy some of those items to send straight to a
friend you could always send them something nice
or I don't know maybe a cheap cardboard box when
it comes to friends you're limited to sending two
items per friend per day so the more friends you
have the faster you'll be able to hit 100 or
nine cannonball so diving was added the game
as part of the July update and you can jump into
the water from ridiculously high heights Here I
am on a third level cliff on my island and you
could still jump off the side you can also do
a front flip into the water if you press a near
the edge after running toward it here's another
one I actually saw on Reddit which is even more
insane as you can see they built ramps up to this
one and number 10 find out exactly when shooting
stars will have it so the animal crossing data
miner ninji has created a free online tool called
media nook which will allow you to find the exact
weather pattern for your island but not only will
it give you the latest rain forecast it will also
reveal the exact second you heard me second that
you can expect to see shooting stars the only real
caveat here is that setting this up will take some
time it's a pretty lengthy process which is why
I've made an entire video walking you through
it I'll include a link above and also below
in the description if you learned something new
from this video hit that like button and please
consider subscribing if you want more Animal
Crossing videos like this and don't forget to
hit that notification bell as well so you'll know
every time I post a new video alright hopefully
you guys learned something new today that's
gonna be it for me I will talk to you again soon